The F-statistic we calculated is greater than our critical value. Therefore, we
reject the null in favor of the alternative. At least one group is
significantly different. And I think we know which one it is. We easily
realized this, simply using our intuiition at the beginning of the lesson. But
usually the situations we use in ova four are much more complicated, and with
much larger data sets. And it's impossible to look at lists of hundreds or
thousands of values and just know if they're different. But also in those those
cases, we wouldn't calculate the F-statistic by hand. We would use software.
The purpose of this lesson was mostly for you to understand the reasoning
behind the F-statistic, and learn how it's calculated. Great job.